from cnn.com
thousands protests as italy's covet pass
becomes mandatory for workers
they say
anyone who is on a payroll in the public
or private sector must have a green pass
with a qr code as proof of either full
vaccination recent recovery from
infection or a negative test within the
previous 48 hours
employees who go to work without the
past risk a fine of up to fifteen
hundred euros seventeen hundred thirty
dollars and suspension without pay
employers could also face fines if they
allow staff to work without it wow yeah
that's uh it's substantially worse than
here in the u.s exactly and the way that
they implemented this was really
sinister because in italy talk of like
the covid you know vaccine passport it
was first deemed a conspiracy theory
it's crazy it's not going to happen here
and then they started to implement it
with restaurants and indoor dining then
they started to implement it with travel
trains buses planes can't get on any of
those if you don't have the green pass
and now their latest
rule here this i don't i don't even want
to say rule their latest decree here by
the italian government is that you can't
work in there in the public sector or
private sector if you don't have a green
pass if you don't have a qr code that
says the government allows you to work
and if you do work you get a fine of a
thousand five hundred euros
um and you need a vaccine to be
compliant every six months with this
quote green pass or a test every 48
hours which is unfeasible so
what's the i i got a question so what's
the option if you say no to all this uh
you're going to jail you're getting
fined until the i mean 1 500 euro fine
for going to work and not having a green
here's here's the best part in the
united states
if you are fired because you didn't get
vaccinated and there was a mandate it's
considered a voluntary resignation
wow
and in many states like new york you
lose unemployment benefits so nurses
that get kicked to the curb literally
have to find another job right away to
make sure that they could even uh pay
the bills so we're in phase two italy
went through phase three and four we're
seeing a lot of countries implement the
same policies only on different
timelines but they're doing the same
thing it's common it's again
it's already here los angeles has some
of the most strictest
covet 19 vaccine passports that they're
going to be implementing cnn has been
cheerleading it saying it's awesome it's
great you know getting permission slips
from the government for every basic
activity is so awesome you know the same
government that runs the dmv yeah i
definitely trust those people to have a
domestic permission slip passport system
i mean it's just ridiculous it's it's
it's insane and and people are standing
up to this people are protesting in mass
i've been tweeting out photos that show
huge amounts of people there's also some
fake photos there's some disinformation
going around but i'm trying to confirm a
lot of this i have some people in italy
that i'm talking to but now unions dock
workers are coming together and they're
doing a quote indefinite blockade of the
ports in italy with them saying we're
going to block this until you get rid of
this domestic passport permission slip
system so it's going to be a very
interesting showdown and clash that
we're going to see unfold in italy in
just a few moments from now it needs to
happen soon because as you guys know
that once they implement this stuff it
doesn't get unimplemented it's done it's
expanded there's no deadline there's no
deadline they're not going to say hey if
everyone is free of covid we're going to
get rid of this or if 90 or 80 they
usually do this
you can't tell someone to sacrifice for
something that has no end to it
that's why we're setting up free
damastan
there needs to be a free damascan in
every state uh and you're setting this
up uh west virginia yeah oh that's
brilliant is there it's not like it's
gonna be an actual big city or anything
but we're gonna have a lot of space so
there's gonna be a lot of a big communal
aspect to it where people can come and
you know we're we're we're sorting it
out we're gonna be growing our own food
we're gonna be doing a lot of
sustainable living stuff ian's gonna
build his free dome geodesic dome we're
gonna we're gonna try and do things in
the most uh environmentally friendly and
economically friendly way to be like
self-sufficient because
look man it's the great reset it's
coming right they want you to own
nothing and be happy well as long as you
have some land and the ability to
produce some of your own stuff then
you'll at least own some stuff and if
the supply chains are breaking down what
i'm really interested in is you know
what can we make in freedom stand what
can we what can we get out of the ground
what can we build ourselves
luke's talking about trade routes and
stuff can we get metals and things like
that and then start doing construction
or even like sourcing raw materials
things like that
ian's talking about pulling carbon from
the air to make graphene maybe this
sparks the graphene revolution because
we can't get iron anymore right you can
pull the carbon dioxide out of the air
then deposit it onto like a copper
palladium alloy at like a thousand
degrees centigrade and it'll deposit
graphene oxide
that's one way to do it there's other
methods too you can take rubber trash
and then hit it called flash graphing
where you hit it with pulse it with
lasers and then turn it into a fine
layer of graphene that requires a lot of
electricity and lasers we need to figure
out how to generate a lot of electricity
yeah locally like geothermal or
something giant wheel nuclear ian runs
in it little mini nuclear plant yeah uh
it sounds much better than the chad for
sure it does
it's solutions not if we just stare at
the problem like this all day every day
we're all going to go insane and then
it's going to end so we have to fix it
yeah
it's funny they set up the autonomous
zone in these cities just by trying to
steal
land or whatever they're colonizing yeah
what do we do we we rightfully negotiate
a treaty for
you know settlement on this year land
and then set up our autonomous zone it's
not an autonomous zone you know we're
just like a normal place with like
business
no it's it sounds like it's weird we
were talking earlier about things
flipping we we're seeing people on the
right i don't know i don't want to say
too conservative like thinking about
communes and going on their own which is
it's good you know there's always been
the preppers as well
to be fair
and i you know
we have to do this soon we have to think
about these things soon so one thing
when i talk about it on my channel i've
been talking about it for a long time is
you know nobody's going to come and save
us like nobody's coming in trump ain't
going to sweep in and fix everything
even if he wins in two years the midterm
elections might be a slap in the wrist
but you know right now they're all in on
this most of the government is in on
this they're just playing their stupid
game and they're resetting on us and
there's like there's stuff i'd love to
say but i i didn't want to say it you
know on your channel you know we were
talking about earlier and i won't say it
here but uh
you know
until we decide we are going to end this
those rules like i said are implemented
they're implemented they're not going
away ever and that's now this word
mandate is just part of our language now
we're completely cool with it so we went
from emerging emergency provisions
mandating that people stay at home for a
couple of weeks to
gavin newsom mandating what a business
can sell on a you know a toil you know
and that's why we chose west virginia
you know you could choose new hampshire
florida texas i think texas is too dense
and that means it's susceptible to
you know leftist manipulations and
things like that for a variety of
reasons what happens we see this in west
virginia where
there will be like a gun range a
shooting range
and it's noisy uh there actually is one
up you know not too far from here it's a
public land where people go shooting
you're not supposed to do it use it as a
range apparently but people do hunting
training or something all the neighbors
can hear the gunshots all day every day
and they're fine with it but liberals
are starting to move in from dc because
they want to get away from the nightmare
they created and go to west virginia
where it's conservative
when they move in they're told when you
buy this property you sign this
disclosure acknowledging there's a
shooting range you know the other side
of the street which presents some
dangers risks and a noise issue but you
accept these things when you move in and
they say yeah no problem
then they tell their friends to move in
and say once we get enough people we can
vote to shut down their range huh and
that's what's been happening things like
that there was like a farm that had like
a dairy farm it was stinky and so people
moved in and they were like you
acknowledge there's a farm here the
smell is you know something that people
are concerned about they said no problem
once they sold all the land around it
the people voted and said shut the farm
down and then all of a sudden you own
this land and they're like sorry the
cops come in and say the people have
spoken
and then you can't run your business
anymore that's you got to watch out for
that's why i'm worried about you know
texas because it's happening in west
virginia too now that's because west
virginia people don't know this is about
an hour from dc it's not that far away
from dc
so new hampshire might be a good idea
but then new hampshire is
i think new hampshire what has going for
is a free state project which is
protecting it and expanding the freedom
west virginia has the inverse problem
they have a lot of people trying to come
into the eastern part that being said
though west virginia has lost a ton of
liberals from the other more urban
cities so i think west virginia is a
good bet
new hampshire is probably i think in the
long term we're actually looking at uh
setting up shop in some capacity in new
hampshire
so uh maybe buying a small piece of land
that way we have a place to be in new
hampshire in the event the free state
project becomes very prominent because
as long as i've been telling luke
nonstop like new hampshire oh great
blasphemy
i've been screaming about new hampshire
forever i've been sending you property
there a few weeks ago luke sends me low
posts i'm like dude this is good right
here because there's already a freedom
stand there there's a great guy called j
noon he could fix and build everything
he's been teaching me pretty much doing
man camp which he does and he helps
people figure out how to get out of the
cities and learn to actually be
self-reliant he's a great guy jay newton
if you haven't heard of him great
awesome part of the free state project
but he he has his own freedoms uh for
edamastan um in new hampshire i want
about the forge
yeah and uh you know
there's a lot of freedom in new
hampshire um and a lot of opportunities
so i love it there i go there for the
summers florida for the cold cold
winters and of course back here with you
guys uh for the foreseeable future texas
is doing all right yeah yeah really
dense stuff and you got that border
problem right these people flooding into
the border is a big risk to texas in
terms of maintaining
you know their
sovereignty
yeah
california
was fine 20 years ago california was
fine like when i was growing up thinking
about like san diego was a right-wing
military town
and los angeles was pretty centrist
san francisco was always weird but it
never ran the state now it runs the
state and now we've seen what happened
like neva las vegas
you know they had these like crazy mask
mandates and i was just like god that
you know gangsters used to run this town
i was just there i'm like
it's oh it's it's so conforming and it
was kind of a turn off and then
arizona's the same way so i yeah i
wouldn't be surprised if uh if texas
flips if if florida flips it it just
depends on what county you're in
so texas and florida are like teetering
between left and right now there's been
some big changes like on the border it
went republican miami went republican
west virginia is the second most trump
supporting state in the country
and so i'm like i like it you know new
hampshire is good but i think in order
to get a good space you got to be
like you got to be kind of far away from
the urban center whereas here
we we get west virginia we're in the
tri-state area but we we we're setting
up for downtown west virginia and it's
like an hour and a half to the airport
so you still get a big urban center
airport not too far away but not too
close
we weighed a lot of options i mean i was
looking at northern maine i was like
i'll take what i can get but satellite
internet can it's not going to cut it
and bringing people out to the middle of
nowhere is too difficult we looked at
rural pennsylvania that would have been
awesome i really wanted to like find
like a dying town and bring industry
back and just like get more jobs and
stuff but maybe maybe we'll do that with
the ferdamastan area and more people
will find jobs and more industry will
grow and we'll be investing continually
in the space to build stuff and set up a
business
you know luke wants to get his head have
his own gun shop so
that would be fun and and um training
facility
and yeah you know growing your own food
yeah yeah owning a shop was brilliant it
was the most freedom i've ever had well
except you know working for on a youtube
channel it's great being your own boss
is abs it's
that's the american dream you know and
you don't need to be rich i never made a
ton of money at the comic store i was so
freaking happy for most of it uh and
i i'm i'm happy now except for the world
falling apart around us uh i'm happy
it's it's hard to to work out in my head
sometimes but
yeah i guess the only problem i had
about moving out of california was
finding internet i mean that that's that
was you know like you said satellite
internet's not going to cut it so i'm
going to have to have it put in myself
especially yeah like you have you know
if you go too far out there's no way
you're gonna get it uh that's the only
problem because i would love to be out
in the middle of nowhere nowhere near a
city not even within 100 miles yep but
that's not an option
uh right now uh there's still a ton of
country i mean texas is cheap that's
even now like compared to compared to
california everything's cheap so yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you